est il possible d'écrire un récit avec
des personnages autochtone sans tomber
dans l'appropriation culturelle
oui bienvenue à paroles autochtone 6 et
mélissa mollen dupuis pour répondre à la
question du sahara cette semaine c'est
vrai que ça peut être difficile des
mamans et les langues se veut prendre
pour ne pas tomber dans l'appropriation
culturelle je dirais que c'est de ne pas
raconter les récits des eaux ne pas
raconter l'historique de quelqu'un un
personnage ou un membre de famille une
communauté même des légendes des fois
sans avoir consulté la communauté qui
est concerné il ya des exemples de
textes justement où est ce que par
exemple on va parler de certains
personnages mais à cause ce n'est pas eu
de consultation des communautés bien les
histoires sont mal raconté où ils sont
même adaptées selon le mode d'écriture
nord-américain eurocentré donc en
consultant les communautés on a plus
l'histoire qui est derrière l'histoire
et ça nous permet de faire de faire
honneur au récit plutôt que de se
l'approprier et de le transformer
complètement et si on enlevait le poids
historique et culturel du récit
cependant tu peux aussi écrire des
histoires du québec un des histoires du
canada des états-unis en ajoutant des
personnages qui sont autochtones qui ont
un passé tant qu'homme surtout quand on
parle de fiction mais bien sûr on invite
à chercher à faire la recherche qu'il
faut pour bien représenter les
communautés autochtones ne pas faire
d'enfant un portrait très simplifiée du
nautic est très complexe
donc c'est toujours une question de
respect sur une question de commettre si
vous présentez puis habituellement
consulter les communautés
c'est toujours la meilleure solution
pour pas se tromper et souvent ça va me
permettre de faire des travers et des
travaux qui vont être en équipe en
groupe et qui vont enrichir ton parcours
d'auteur donc en espérant que ça a pu
répondre à ta question
en espérant que vous n'allez pas hésité
à nous en envoyer d'autres et à partager
ses vidéos
je vous souhaite une belle semaine